you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're disabled foster
kid you've got it all Vince you could
have one superpower what would you think
everybody chooses flight you know why so
they can fly away from this conversation
no cuz heroes fly well you need your
fake family to stand up for you hey man
sorry about that
daily backs
I choose you ask a peon
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
sure wait for real okay
Shazam you're the only person I know
that knows anything about this Cape
Crusader stuff tonight yeah that's crazy
right what are your superpowers
superpowers dude I don't even know how
to pee in this thing get the feeling
just pin you fly if I quit your panel I
still buy procedures
if my quickness you okay why are you
talking
no I don't think it's gonna buff out
your phone charge your phone charge help
think like a bad guy right
I didn't fight
you have full immunity
I'm Wolfram you're dead sorry about your
window but now you're welcome for not
getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
you